bruits de transformers cor de chasse
toute la journée les agents forestiers
se sont fait entendre dans les rues de
mâcon parmi les manifestants les à agent
à l'office national de la forêt depuis
2012 comme ses collègues elle craint une
privatisation de l'eau nf notre
direction générale cherche la
rentabilité de la forêt c'est à dire que
tout ceci et environnement elle s'insère
elle sincère juste pourra faire son fer
bonne pub et à terme cette émission
qu'on va perdre contrats plus les agents
craignent ainsi les dégâts occasionnés
sur les forêts sans une gestion durable
notamment lors du martèlement c'est à
dire la désignation des arbres à abattre
confier de plus en plus à des salariés
de droit privé la hiérarchie pont à leur
mettre une pression qui est beaucoup
plus difficile à mettre sur nous puisque
nous on a quand même un statut qui nous
protège si c'est plus les fonctionnaires
qui martèlent les boire ça va être des
gens sont pas fonctionnaires et qui
martèleront peut-être rendement donc on
peut très bien enlevé à la ferait des
choses il faudrait pas enlever elle
consiste également en la protection de
l'eau des sols du climat de la bio
diversité des paysages et si les
missions sont nombreuses
al'inverse les agences se raréfient au
delà blacas environnementale ya une
casse sociale tant en termes de baisses
d'effectifs
c'est en quelques années on a perdu 25%
des effectifs après avoir été reçue à la
préfecture
les agents en planter des chênes
symbolisant la forêt et les missions des
forestiers devant la gare toutes les
missions